l'élève isabelle morini-bosc que j'aime
je vous donnerai ma note également 12 ça
va peut-être être pimentée oui à main
vous avez dû vous n'aurait pas mieux dit
je veux juste faire vous les regardez
votre poignet tôt mais comment vous dire
oui et j'ai horreur qu'on parle de moi
c'est non c'est vrai à bas ça tombe mal
congénital c'est vrai ouais bon
congénitale ouais ouais et dans
congénitale ya aller alors
[Applaudissements]
là vous faites une rentrée vous êtes
magnifique et je voulais déjà dit il
m'en coller des coques pas au top de
l'eczéma
en tout cas vous donner envie j'ai eu
mal ou raconté wajih si monsieur malan
franchement je trouve ça rentre dans le
fondement ça fait 6 circulaire marine
meriem mehdi clic on s'en fout c'est
tout cas les sens
j'avais un truc qui pendouille voulait
déjà dit plus le centre devient moche
pour attirer l'attention sur un
périphérique
tu pourras sortir avec un jeune comme
gens me connaissent ils savent depuis
longtemps elle avait des cheveux longs
bouclés ressembler une princesse
suédoise après la guerre matin fait
mieux mais j'en ai second tour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on y verra tic tac ça va calmer le temps
qu'elle le sus ce sera la fin des bars
[Musique]
moi c'est beaucoup c'est mal ça m'a pris
deux protégés oui quelques jours j'étais
tout à l'heure quand elle est rentrée
dans la loge m'a enfin vaincu merci à ma
très bien pour moi vous êtes la number
one de classe on a fermé des zones
occupées depuis on a je vous le dis le
quart d'heure sophitia camille combal ya
tout ça de l on dit on va démarrer par
jean luc lemoine sur isabelle
morini-bosc alors dans les points
positifs déjà c'est quand on fait la
feuille de match c'est la première qu'on
met sur la feuille de match
c'est isabelle terrin vous regarderez
bien même la présence autour de la table
c'est celle qui est loin devant nous on
perdra tous là dessus alors et c'est
celle qui vient fait le plus d'émissions
isabelle et avec maxime gainey ouais
j'avais oublié maximum sinon toujours
les points positifs
l'endurance et de l'autodérision ce qui
est super important parce que à la
demande du rance déjà quand on met en
doute son honnêteté intellectuelle
concernant m6 est aussi son endurance
aussi pour toutes les vannes sur
sondages parce que l epa sillage et que
ça et au début on prenait quelques
précautions maintenant de les gens
l'appellent mamie donc et on a quand
même fait un instant c'est affectueux
mamie ça vous plaît énormément
un à temps partiel ce qui est ce qui est
bien aussi c'est qu'on vit dans les
paroles a toutefois quelque chose à dire
jusqu'à moi jean luc je comprends rien
de ce qu'a nié c'est pas grave ça se
parle tout seul dans les points négatifs
seule arme c'est que quand il donne la
parole elle a toujours quelque chose à
dire et raconter des anecdotes on sait
pas où et par elle non plus et puis il
ya un problème de bruit de fond je
presse que ce qu'ils soient si à côté
d'elle souffre parce qu'elle commande
tout en permanence comme s'ils étaient
devant sa télé mais bon je serai pas
insulter l'avenir
elle a la gentillesse quand même de
prouver très à son goût donc c'est
peut-être ma future 9 thérèse pour jeu
mais 8
ocaña isabelle morini-bosc vous en
pensez quoi
alors moi je trouve 91 points positifs
que tu as une passion c'est absolument
se réalise avec toutes les critiques les
vannes que tu te prends ce qu'on a pu le
faire faire on t'a vu dans la situation
assez invraisemblable oui c'est d'aider
des vannes incessantes sur ton âge que
parfois tu devant ce tuto flagey parfois
tu pratiques effectivement comme le dit
jean luc loto de raison ce que je trouve
assez admirable du support du gym qui
crie qui écrit dessus par mois j'ai
consultés m'ont au réel après ma
première ma première émission parce que
c'est quand même un haut niveau sonore
assez fort quoi du coup dans les points
négatifs moi j'ai été assez surprise
quand je suis arrivé dans l'émission
parce que vous la regardez avant je
pensais que c'était quelqu'un de patient
est ce que je constate c'est que quand
on fait part d'un avis contraire retient
dans les débats tu es vraiment tu change
complètement de tout sur les grilles fut
interrompt tu cries tu n'écoutes pas et
je trouve que c'est dommage parce que on
tue à montrer que tu es quelqu'un de
patient et moi je ne plus en faire en
faire les preuves lors des défauts
j'exprime à la ville un avis divergent
du tien c'est difficile de contre
argumenter contre toi parce que tu
interrompt en criant toutefois je pense
que tu es voilà tu as un personnage
comme ça a été dit qu a tout à fait sa
place
tpm paix mais qui gagnerait peut-être à
faire preuve d'indulgence vis-à-vis des
personnes qui sont pas d'accord avec toi
aimer je te présente voilà mes
encouragements et ma note que j'ai pas
le temps d'écrire donc c'est un set
cette voie là c'est bon ça va se gâter
peut-être caroline manon ça va se gâter
j'ai réfléchi tout l'après midi était
vraiment bien
[Applaudissements]
vous n'êtes pas où il m'a mis 10 massie
mais c'est passé du temps pour me
reposer afin de réfléchir pendant
l'émission et a dit non mais j'ai
réfléchi parce que ce avec le but du jeu
c'est aussi d'aller gratter un peu là où
ça fait mal et j'ai du mal à faire face
avec toi parce que malgré ce petit
défaut qui est à mon sens que parfois tu
as un petit peu fatigante un petit
dessous lente et c'est vraiment le seul
point négatif non mais bon c'est rien
par rapport aux qualités je trouve drôle
je te trouve intelligente je trouve que
tu pourrais être opposés sur ta
personnalité et on est un peu la
chouchoute et que malgré tout on sent
que tu bosses et que tu travailles et
que tu es là voilà le rapport que
d'anecdotes voudrais que tu fasses par
contre ma famille que tu viennes un
dimanche déjeuner chez nous je trouve
que tu as un pilier de l'action il ya
une star dans tpm paix je trouve que ces
trois je te met neuf voix la droite
pour moi il a depuis une des personnes
les plus bienveillante de cette émission
est gentil qui m'a hyper bien accueilli
vous attend keller pour le concours de
pom pom girls
mais non non c'est très mignon mignon
donc voilà qui m'a super bien accueilli
par la gentille est c'est grâce à toi
que j'ai été aussi à l'aise dans cette
émission pour tes points positifs ben
moi je trouve hyper rigolotes comme ce
qu'on a déjà dit enfin voilà
autodérision c'est hyper rigolo de ta
part ensuite pour les points ah oui et
aussi j'aime beaucoup de danser avec toi
pendant les lives jeta ses allées et
d'autres choses alors points négatifs il
faut que tu penses à réparer tes
oreilles parce que ça peut être un
inconvénient pour l'émission alors
réparez désormais vous croyez vous tu
crois que tu vérifies les niveaux tu me
reparler j'aurais également à et tu me
fais le châssis est bien allé chez
veritas veritas où tout est donc un levé
la main avant chaque intervention parce
que c'est vrai que des fois on a
tendance à trop c'est trop pour un
patois d'être derrière tu lèves labatut
en tête alors la note salée et la note 9
sur 10 auj
monsieur grec classe là je vous dis je
vous ai mis les meilleures notes à le
reste c'est un peu différent et on était
sur le coup ces deux clubs allemands ni
va vous mettre la main sur le très bien
les chéris alors on était sur les notes
on a eu des notes de kelly n'a eu des
notes de jean luc lemoine les notes de
rokhaya de caroline j'attends maintenant
la note de pierre ménès mon chéri alors
ça fait pas longtemps que je suis là oui
je te connais c'est très peu avant et
maintenant je me dis que je vais adorer
j'ai adoré ta gentillesse ta
bienveillance des clins d'oeil pendant
l'émission
as tu as le bon goût d'être souvent
d'accord avec moi j'aime beaucoup je te
trouve extrêmement drôle extrêmement
cultivé ça j'avais eu l'occasion de le
cul de le constater au grand concours
des animateurs
ah oui les meilleurs sur tf1 sur ces
huit bons dans les points faibles je
suis pas fou foot à masnières peuvent
saper je suis pas fou pu mettre tout le
temps un truc dans tes zohra est dans
ton nez ouais et encore on n'est pas là
chez elle mais malgré tout pour la
culture la gentillesse la drôlerie jeu
mais et c'est pas souvent chez moi
neuf aussi là
cherry aller et maxime kenwood points
positifs
tu est calée sur les médias ça fait
trente-cinq quant à sa bouche ou cinq
ans que tu en fais tu as débuté mineurs
peut-être oui à des analyses sont
souvent justes
isabelle ta vraie force c'est que tu
regarde la télévision je connais par
coeur il est mécontent clan ce serait
n'importe quel jeune même s'il est pas
intéressant
tu sais vraiment pas quoi répondre enfin
tu à l'esprit vif tu as toujours le bon
mot et a beaucoup d'auto des défaites à
l'esprit vivons et qui parle mariage
[Rires]
concernant les points négatifs a tué
bavard beaucoup trop bavarde
tu parles quand il ne faut pas tu ne
lève jamais la main alors que nous en
face on se remet tant on attend
patiemment qu'on nous donne la parole
mais bien sûr tu l'apprends avant nous
donc tu ne grille la politesse pour une
fois mature comme toi qui est un peu de
tact ça tu pourrais pas te le modifier
enfin ya des débats dans lesquels tu
perds parfois un peu le fil il ya la
divagation dans l'air donc attention on
est neuf
autour de la table ainsi alors donc
apprécié le show prévu les angoisses te
plaît arrête un tout à fait licite pour
ton parcours et pc
et voilà mb tuer une bête médiatique y
en a eu oui isabelle morini-bosc c'est
un acronyme pour moi tu es une bête
médiatique drôle et attachante quatre
points forts tes analyses ta réflexion
pour moi sens du milieu autre chose
aussi ton absence de cynisme alors que
tu as compris que ce métier était très
cynique
ça ça me plaît beaucoup tenté la daronne
de l'autodérision sa définitivement un
petit point faible
non pour moi tu es une sorte de comment
dire de entre tatie danielle et lady
gaga
j'adore that à la croisée des chemins
car elle est plus déçu parce qu'elle est
déjà faible
enfin lyon mb je veux que tu arrêtes de
te maltraités de te dénigrer il faut
arrêter avec je ne suis pas souple je
suis trop âgé
j'ai des bijoux j'ai envie de panna
cotta j'ai plus de libido stop chez lui
ça moi je veux que tu te fasses du bien
je veux que tu parles bien de toi
mb tu à la fois intemporel mb maboul et
bordélique
j'adore alors et je te mets un imite
film trop bien
mais la pandémie djembé d'abord d'abord
isabelle tu as un soleil dans l'émission
revenir sur elliott bah oui quoi qu'il
arrive je dois avoir un parent on a dit
on l'a dit est un élément totalement
indispensable au niveau des médias c'est
vrai que tu connaisses à parker au pour
les points faibles
alors les points faibles il y en a un
que j'ai noté c'est vrai tu n'écoutes
pas et parfois ça ça énerve même le chef
parce que même parfois tu essayes de
prendre là je vais devenir prendre la
parole
regardez je crois qu'elle quelqu un qu
un message pour vous d'ailleurs regardez
olap à anny duperey je crois qu'elle est
un message pour lui mais regardez oui
voilà alors à venir regarder
qu'est ce que vous dites elle n'écoute
pas elle n'écoute pas elle n'écoute pas
et quand on est beaucoup à table elle
n'écoute pas regardez regardez verdict
peut-être qu'on me voilà bref sans qu'on
ne peut plus les boire et bien il ya un
autre problème c'est que richard gasquet
qui va venir en surprises ouais
[Rires]
et quand tu te lances dans une anecdote
moi j'ai le temps d'y penser deux fois
avant que la finissent donc honnêtement
on va passer pas beaucoup c'est pas
beaucoup mais mais mais pour tout ça je
te mets un magnifique 8 et tu as toutes
les félicitations après une petite
surprise
alors on va on va finir par vous
jean-michel d'abord j'aimerais il ya
quelqu'un qui tenait avec l'absolu mans
pour votre conseil de classe cette
personne elle est là ou là
[Musique]
alors mis la clé sous la porte et lui
c'est la guerre entre vous il voulait
être là pour le conseil de classe mais
j'imagine ces coups durs absolument à
être là isabelle je n'ai que des
compliments à vous faire et d'ailleurs
je ne vais parler que de vos points
forts et maintenant que je suis en face
de vous je remarque tous ses points
forts
et en plus sont propres de base ni
recevoir de coups de pancartes
donc c'est formidable pour moi mais vous
êtes extraordinaire vous raconter des
anecdotes toujours les mêmes mais avec
un tel talent que sont nés exceptionnel
parler à tord et à travers vous n'avez
rien à dire sur le sujet et avec une
réelle ans ça devient magnifique
et puis franchement vous dansez vous
chantez vous jouer au badminton
maintenant que vous êtes là vous relevez
lui vous regarder à côté de qui vous
êtes mais heureusement que vous êtes là
non franchement isabelle c'est
magnifique alors bien sûr jamais vous
critiquerez m6 mais c'est pas grave ça
je m'en charge
ben en occupe je tenais absolument être
là et je vais vous mettre une note
exceptionnelle
je dis bien exceptionnel franchement
isabelle merci de m'avoir accueillie
pour tout ce que vous faites tout ce que
vous êtes je vous accorde un sublime 3
[Applaudissements]
oui il a tu sais que je t'adore même si
parfois on se chamaille un peu et assure
toi un énorme pas fort c'est à souplesse
n'a pas parlé mais c'est vrai que
mitterrand celui encore tu laisses ta
jambe droite pas de poids à la verticale
donc voilà un gros big up un chercheur
comment merci à grog un gros big up aux
chercheurs qui font des progrès dans les
hanches en plastique franchement
maintenant on fait des choses
extérieures grand big up
franchement c'est écrit au cordeau alors
malheureusement quelques quelques points
faibles a déjà tu étais points.la
clients ça c'est un peu gênant ça qui
peuvent faire la pire des docks tu
continues en dire du bien extérieure
tlpe 6 donc essaye d'être un peu plus
objective troussage préféré soit un peu
plus disciplinés on l'a dit sur le fait
que tu mettes des doigts ou des objets
dans tous tes orifices oui un peu ça n'a
pas de sens ils sont contents cyrille
parant d'arc à alès le parti ne continue
pas parler sur lui faire face en échange
ça fait huit ans que tu fais cette
émission de bordel voilà autrement de
bon ton de points forts et faibles
c'est là où prend rien au jeu vous
voulez repasser peut-être ton prono
rétrograde appuyé sur le voyage à pied
soit loyale voilà on comprend rien au
jeu aux fans j'exagère un peu en jean tu
les comprends mais tout est terminé mais
c'est vrai que sur le fait deux jours de
suite ça marche un peu mieux le nombre
et surtout tu radote ça c'est là le pire
des reproches que je te file isabelle
honnête ça fait mille fois qu'il lui dit
tu as trahi dans un zoo tafer pékin
express que tu étais portraitiste que tu
as était comestible kahn a un gros zizis
extra on en a marre tous les essais d'un
peu de changer les anecdotes mais je
t'adore quand même et surtout dans 20
ans j'aimerais surtout avoir encore la
forme que tan en battant dans ce tome
est quand même très beau 2
[Applaudissements]
que bravo l'emmy alors vous combien vous
mais comment vous mettez moi je me
mettais à eybens isabelle moi je vais
vous mettre votre note c'est vrai que
jean luc a dit un truc break enjeux
constitue les équipes le matin la
première que je mets à la table c'est
isabelle maury bottes isabel vous savez
que je vous aime je ne peux pas faire
les missions sans vous 1 et j'espère
qu'on leur fera toujours ensemble je
vous mets isabelle huit et demi
auj
[Applaudissements]
vous remercie tous et je voudrais te
dire aux cayes a alors pardon parce que
oui là je me suis rendu compte que cela
que je la coupe est si j'ose dire oui
mais on va pas faire ça non mais mais en
revanche là je te jure que j'écoute
d'accord merci maman mais effectivement
de quoi jeter interrompu je te prie de
mx2 sur les 2,8 à des notices qui donne
des internautes à les livres du coeur
donc la moyenne très vite cette virgule
et non les twittos suite
[Applaudissements]